une première en france l'école militaire
de saint cyr l'école est inauguré ce
mercredi 4 avril locaux du bts
cyberdéfense une formation créée en
septembre dernier qui a pour objectif de
former des experts en informatique pour
protéger des données
c'est une grande fierté parce que c'est
une formation très très innovante qui
s'est bâti en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale et qui a réussi à
produire une formation très spécifique
qui n'a d'équivalent nulle part ailleurs
pour former ses 32 à coeur en l'uniforme
un programme spécifique a été imaginé on
fait beaucoup d'informatique de la
programmation du réseau un enseignement
spécifique un physique mais également de
la culture générale des langues est une
formation une initiation aux techniques
et à l'organisation de la cybersécurité
ce cursus pourrait leur permettre
d'accéder à l'école de formation des
sous-officiers de l'armée de terre ou
aux services de renseignement du
ministère des armées dans la plupart du
monde et interconnectés par
l'information par les lords ya de
l'informatique donc je pense que c'est
clairement le futur rien de plus
important aujourd'hui
la section a déjà reçu près de 800
candidatures pour la rentrée 2010 8 pour
seulement 30 de places